rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message disrupt your standard
over to you Lisa Nichols into so many
people all around the world who are
living this duality one I want more but
two I don't want to disrupt what I have
and the challenge is in order for you to
have a break through to the next level
your your your standard your average and
your ordinary has to be disrupted will
say oh Lisa how do I do this and I go do
this this this and this I give you the
steps and the next thing they say is
that's so hard I'm sorry did you think
you're breathtaking life will come on a
merry-go-round did you think you're
gonna do the swings and get there you're
gonna sweat so get up ready to sweat get
up
ready to forgive the perceiving Li
unforgivable get up ready to take the
higher Road even when the smallness in
you wants to get engaged avoid the fight
because the fight keeps you in the
little you when you're committed to
being the bigger version of yourself
yeah you gonna have to say some things
you never said and do some things you've
never done so you can meet the man the
woman you've always known yourself to be
every major breakthrough that I've ever
made in my life in my business has not
come from applying a specific strategy
and that's what saved me it's by raising
my standards it's by changing my mindset
it's by altering what I am no longer
willing to accept in myself and from the
people around me and in my environment
and when you can make that mental shift
then you're more able to pay attention
to the strategies because I can give you
tons of strategies and tons of tactics
and how to grow your business but unless
you have the mindset of growth and
you're ready to push through your
limiting beliefs you're not going to
listen to the strategies and you're not
gonna apply them to your life so the
earliest one I can remember is thinking
back to my first business of 19 years
old I'm selling biotech software
two people three times my age with PhDs
the science was my worst subject growing
up and I always thought I don't know
anything about science I'm Way too young
I have no degree in this they're not
gonna listen to me and that held me back
for the longest time and it was until I
realized that all they really care about
is that my software can help them in
their business in their research once I
realized that by having one conversation
my values rose my standards shifted I
was able to move beyond the I'm too
young to be able to do this even more
recent looking at at this business
Toronto dine salsa I became an investor
in this company a while ago I ended up
taking over this business at the
beginning of 2016 and before doing that
I had opportunity to take over the
company but I never I never thought that
I wanted to I didn't think I could I
didn't think I knew enough about the
details I didn't think I could run it
and do my YouTube channel and do my
other businesses and help entrepreneurs
and do invest in and speaking I don't
think I could do it all together and
then I believed that I could and then I
did right it's a mind game we trick
ourselves out of doing things that
aren't in line with what we want to do
because we believe that we can't
you've been still for me even mister
belief right my biggest limiting belief
is still the belief that I can't do
something and so I think the hardest
part is recognizing the limiting beliefs
that you have because they're so
subconscious they're so automatic
they're so pattern istic that you just
fall into them regularly without having
to think about it you don't have to
think about living small you just do
everyday you don't have to think about
holding yourself back you just do
everyday it's automatic and so an
exercise that I like to use that maybe
you guys can apply is just looking at
yourself in a mirror and asking yourself
what are the big goals that you have and
why have you not accomplished them yet
why have you not hit that goal yet so
you look in the mirror say like why have
I not hit this goal and see what comes
back and if you're coming down to a
strategy it's not the reason if you're
coming down to complaining or blaming
somebody else like the government hasn't
passed regulation for it yet or the
country I'm in socks or the currency or
whatever right my parents education
system whatever if it's blaming somebody
else that's not the answer either it's
nobody else's fault and it's also not a
specific strategy it's you it's the
mindset if you can get down to that if
you can figure out that specific issue
and solve it that's where you get your
next phase of growth so if I ask myself
with the software company why am I not
having more success yet I'm too young
they won't take me seriously I don't
have the degree they won't take me
seriously that was my reasoning that was
my rationale made total logical sense
that was the key to breakthrough that to
be able to unlock it for TBS I'm too
busy to be able to take on this new
business I don't know enough about the
details to be able to run the operations
switching that right bringing on Alex
training him having a transition plan
unlocking that allowed me to believe
that I could and so I did and it doesn't
always happen overnight like that some
beliefs can just change in an instant
and now you're off on a new path and
some take more time to develop but
recognizing them as the game recognizing
where you are holding yourself back and
where you need to increase the standard
disrupt the standard your current
standard to get to the next level
that's the game the best example I have
is the mirror test I hope you tried it
so the question today today is I want
you to try that mirror test I want you
to look at yourself in the mirror and
say why have I not achieved this goal
whatever it is for you what's the answer
that comes back write it down in the
comments below
and hopefully by writing it down you can
help release it and if you can't figure
out what the limiting belief behind it
is maybe fellow members of belief nation
can jump in and support you too I would
love to hear from you please leave your
answer down in the comments below so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much loved and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
event spresso
more expresso give me go
Gonzalez what do you think about the
comfort zone I think it's the worst
place you could ever be when you're
hungry you want more when you're wildly
successful you can embrace your hard
work and be proud of it when you're in
the comfort zone it's just we become our
standards in many ways if you are
surrounded by B players or average
performers and that is your standard
then your mindset will operate at the
standard that is that is offered to you
by the people around you I mean we do
become our social orbit and if you are
at a standard internally I want to be a
game changer in my field I want to be
BIW the best there ever was I want to be
the van Gogh and the Rembrandt of
Technology or whatever field you play in
then your behavior always matches your
internal identity and your inner
standards so your standards are
important your standards for your
friendships your standards for the
quality of the work you do the standards
of your languaging the standards of the
nutrition you put into your body the
standards of your love life the
standards of your mindset the standards
of the way you occur in the world and so
my invitation for you regardless of what
you do is that you raise your game to a
place called world class and that is all
about being a game changer now I should
caution you and I don't like that word
because language is so powerful and
caution is a word that really is a
little dramatic but I want to caution
you which is as you leave the herd and
the crowd and perhaps the cult of
mediocrity and rise to being a game
changer it's a very disruptive act and
you actually threaten the masses of
people around you and that's why every
visionary was first ridiculed before
they were revered and I'm sure you've
experienced it you want to say you say
you know I want to take my fitness to a
whole new level of world class or I want
to take my craft to a whole new level of
world class or maybe you're raising your
game financially and then you share it
with those you love or your friend your
friends and maybe your friends are those
you love and they laugh at you and how
many times have we given up on a dream
because we were mocked by the people
around you and all I'm suggesting to you
is when you get laughed at and ridiculed
and what people don't understand your
next level of world class that just
means you've got a great dream and that
just means you're on the path of growth
so be a game-changer this album is very
much it's rooted in my comfort zone but
there are certain times where I step out
of the comfort zone and the reason I
chose sing has to sort of lead single
for it that being step out the compos
owners I had an acoustic ballad song I
wanted to put out first and whenever I
played its people they were like no it's
nice yeah really cool really nice song
when you played sing to people it really
polarized everyone they were like they
hated it or they loved it but they spoke
about it a lot you know he'd speak to
people to be like oh yeah I heard about
that song because so-and-so is talking
about it but no one was talking about
the acoustic gene so I thought by
sticking out a song that sort of makes
people talk it would be a lot better for
ya if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or so it would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details